символічно переговори найрічніша
початку революції видно sti
генпрокурор Юрій Луценко виріс
дороги обговорити зі злочинцями
міжнародного кримінального суду
можна вести розслідування у разі не в
прато євромайданівців який аргумент
і луценко повісь до голови
генпрокуратура на види ляя чим ще
на початку листопада генпрокурор заявляв
дасть духа святого через не підтримували
цінності у Києві
та інших українських місцях стала частиною
на n з козла дуже iv столітті виробили до
окупації крима тв де на донбасі а це
ж без посередників по до п'ят та розвиток
міжнародного кримінального суду
луценка 4 генеральний прокурор після
революції видно у всіх а по
фартуха обіцяла розслідувати викладені
майдану
синтез результат але
потім ще кримінальний суд забирай патча
все листя у справимо майдану
затікала не так вже й адвокат роду ніж за
хабла героєм небесної сотні а джен і
пакла дають вали як спаді ванна офісі
спадщина в Україні
сам цьому на початку жовтня пара дала мкс
свої матеріали піти з права
суть документів адвокати на розвал про шоу
зі світу ванька в позитивності однак
означало ще ставила собі зауважу до вас
ти широко масштабність обоз
автоматичний випадок не має права майдану
але дала міжнародному кримінальному
суду відповідь до кози сама системність
і широкомасштабно закрут критерію ким
та криється міжнародно кримінальний суд
відвіз виручи до проведення хмари инж з
праву у лютому 2014
верховна рада схопила за яву праві
знання юрисдикції мкс диво випадку не про
то люди a nasty scoin їх каримо лист вам
держави друк євромайдану 1 хто де суза
і виправити суд не здасть на кіль
кістки даних про сплановані та
систематичний характер акцій нині шпіц
готові україни навіть дадуть кову
інформацію тебе праворуч може руйнувати з
мертвою точкою проте стогнати від сочі не
буду відома авів торак після переговорів
старовин оптимізму піти з права та так їй
ризику додати прокурор до мкс чудо криму
такі ситуації на острові пиво в porsche
була названа
та призначену міжнародному конфлікту
точно вимкнено зараз право майдану 100
на доступне ланку ути мулан сушіння